hello and welcome to this video playing
van impe fun input yeah I know okay he
plays this stuff to see if I which I
yeah I mean it's not a good opening but
i don't really i know i really have
looked at it so own what's the something
i'm just going to take it check okay so
it's all hard to believe that this
should be okay for black what's the
compensation okay if I just got a ce5
hiscott night to you form okay Queen d3
is probably going Queen to c6 ok so i'll
cover the poem
Queenie to maybe what is he going to do
Quincy 6i guess here it's hard not to
play this move I think it's really cool
that him not even spent a second on all
this so it seems to be a well within
what he expects him interesting okay so
grabbing this pawn um so what's the deal
I would like to go if I but it's got 95
so that's not that's not that attractive
maybe i need f3l to cover to cover it
yeah maybe this forever 3i it's got d5
probably okay so not d5 it looked like a
good move and now i think it is not as
convincing maybe it's got night h for
life okay will seem let h5 maybe like a
92 yeah here i have f form this should
be good
so what's the deal night to a form a BSS
idea yeah i would like to play be three
but it looks it looks loose when I takes
me three is coming against this yeah a
four is annoying maybe I have to do this
you might drop back and then I don't
know what to do with it okay let's
prepare be three
okay so maybe I just take it
yeah well with his bishops he has some
compensation some compensation not sure
if it's enough what he definitely has is
a big advantage on the clock as he
played all those moves are very very
quickly my idea is just to play rupee
one in 95 and then it's not clear what
is not what is bishops are doing what
the other one maybe get out of the
diagonal maybe not a big difference 195
next and then his rooks and bishops look
quite stupid of course now he starts to
think the moment where the position is
already pretty much bad even though it's
not not easy to convert a horse let's
see you know neither has to stay on d4
this is coming around how to do it here
now that's a good move actually looking
at C toon might be five he could take on
c2 unfortunately otherwise it would be a
would be a nice move so and yeah it's
extremely difficult to convert rupee
three though yeah I've got Ruby three
coming
and he cannot remove the kind of move
the route back he had to take back this
is very nice that I can check that I was
able to get rid of one look ok he has
this opportunity here for work to h3 and
fortunately hmm that's not nice 94
though ok no it's not a move chick
huh it's unfortunate time morning
tickets to the gets to h3 em
Jeff that's fair it's difficult to play
em my rook is very misplaced objectively
why dessert a lot better but the rook is
pretty difficult to play here and it's
got those dangerous pawns
you can really just play for my rook is
totally off check check
maybe I should have done mighty fall
down
and
yeah what a weird game check check
check shouldn't underestimate age porn
check and I'll of blundering the blood
eh phone okay check check check check
draw our third game drown oh damn now
Kim whatever your game I mean he appear
black should be completely outplayed and
I think he is but I probably should
insert h4 maybe g3 or something I just
need a little bit of precision in this
but in this situation okay let's have a
look at this opening I think it was
that's really strange stuff generally
speaking c5 is a pretty awful move Queen
a 5c three Quincy 593 is very good for
white and chat me this is also cannot be
good I mean it's very very unlikely um
93 is given by the engine as almost
winning for White Knight f6 5 94 95 to
let the engine is on one point something
1.2 I don't know it that's a lot I mean
it looks pretty awful but okay well this
is also not looking too bad but he
definitely had some play I mean
especially here if he would have played
d5 I think at full Finn annoying ok this
is also probably good no night age five
instead of 90
7 this is what I expected and I wasn't
really sure what to do if i give i go
here they can take and plans either form
there are plenty of a DSM is very active
but yeah this it probably should go back
to c5 no I mean no I get an excellent
blockade after Luke III here I get a
much better version then than in the
game because Roxy three King b---two is
pointless now and young engine just
wants to do this and gives white one
point which is probably here just the
case those are very strong and never
caught up yet here he got this counter
play going with oops check check with
the way through cage three okay actually
I could have played up Jim one here yeah
this is just bad back but it is
difficult to play because his peace
bishop and pawns are easier to play with
my my rook being offside the engine
gives us and white is winning if the
engine certainly we will disposition but
it's not easy other set for human player
because the pawns and bishops are easier
to play yeah the way it went they are
probably check ways to improve check OOP
t6 again seems to be a lot better at
constant move but ok um with 30 seconds
it's pretty much clear that nobody
going to play perfectly here yeah no I
just have to get the pawn to draw check
fortunately a drug change porn checking
the King coming over this it Roger chat
chat chat was a clean room okay well
thanks for watching